qu'est ce qui fait un hit comment
expliquer le succès de telle ou telle
musique et surtout existe-t-il une
recette magique qui ferait de n'importe
quelle musique un succès planétaire
alors spoiler non ça ne se passe pas
comme ça il n'y a pas de recette magique
il ya quand même beaucoup d'éléments de
réponse qu'on va voir ensemble
aujourd'hui et pour pousser la recherche
à fond je suis dit que ce serait quand
même aussi intéressant d'en parler avec
un artiste et en l'occurrence pas
n'importe lequel c'est une superstar
tout simplement c'est le deuxième
artiste le plus écouté de la décennie
sur spotify pour la vidéo pour regarder
aujourd'hui donc j'ai rencontré et
sheeran
[Musique]
alors être sheeran s'est tout simplement
50 millions d'albums vendus à travers le
monde plusieurs tournées dont une
tournée divide qui est la tournée la
plus rentable de l'histoire avec plus de
775 millions de dollars de recettes mais
surtout des stades remplis partout dans
le monde on pourrait citer notamment
chez rovio le morceau le plus trimer de
l'histoire sur spotify avec près de 3
milliards des gouttes et enfin c'est
aussi un nouvel album i qualls qui sort
le 29 octobre qui révèle l'artiste sur
de nouveaux sujets et qui promet d'être
un immense succès et ce comme en
témoigne notamment l'excellent démarrage
de son single bad abed serait autant
dire que les hits et bien et sheeran
salle connais j'ai donc rencontré pour
qu'il nous partage sa vision c'est une
chance assez unique et vous allez donc
entendre ces éléments de réponse à de
nombreuses reprises dans cette vidéo au
passage si vous êtes nouveau et que vous
découvrez cette chaîne principale hugo
décrypte au delà de celles d actu du
jour est bien bien venu écouter
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour nous
soutenir et pour ne pas louper les
vidéos suivantes alors déjà comment sont
peut-être par définir ce qu'on entend
par it ou alors par tube un terme aussi
qu'on utilise pas mal en français selon
la définition stricte du dictionnaire
c'est tout simplement une chanson à
succès alors on est d'accord dit comme
ça c'est très flou mais en fait beaucoup
s'accordent à dire aujourd'hui que un
hit en fait c'est un morceau qui connaît
un immense succès un instant t mais
surtout un morceau qui durent dans le
temps
nasri
et un hit c'est pas forcément quelque
chose qu'on peut prédire mais ya quand
même pas mal d'éléments de réponse et
d'éléments essentiels que ce soit en
termes de musicalité de plateformes de
streaming ou encore d'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui et vous
allez le voir du coup c'est absolument
passionnant et vous commencez donc
rentrons un peu plus dans les détails
sur les éléments musicaux ça en
l'occurrence ça paraît assez évident
donc on va en parler uniquement très
rapidement mais pour faire un litre
c'est bien la grande majorité des
producteurs sont plutôt d'accord pour
dire que faut évoquer des thèmes qui est
bien parle au plus grand nombre en gros
le public doit réussir à s'identifier à
la chanson il faut donc que le message
de la chanson les concernent et les
touches c'est sans doute pour ça que la
grande majorité des hits parle de sujets
universels comme l'amour l'amitié la
famille etc c'est ce qui peut expliquer
notamment le succès de photographes
pareil sheeran qui parle de rupture
amoureuse
mon corps de wyngaert l'art des chansons
très personnelles date sheeran et qui
est inspirée notamment de son ex petit
ami d'anna lena
[Musique]
mais le menu
d'ailleurs pour la petite anecdote et
bien c'est l'une des chansons et plus
jouer encore aujourd'hui lors des
mariages
[Musique]
darling
pour résumer donc et sheeran parle de
sujets très personnelle intime presque
en fait c'est le cas notamment dans son
nouvel album et c'est ce qui peut
expliquer que ça parle à autant de monde
une étude publiée dans la revue royaume
tahiti prize a analysé 500 mille titres
diffusés entre 1985 et 2005 sans milou
il faut pas les choses à moitié et ils
ont comparé en gros les titres qui sont
devenus des tubes avec les titres qui au
contraire ont pas mal bidet et l'une de
leur conclusion c'est que les chansons
qui cartonnent sont très souvent plus
festives plus joyeuse et plus dansantes
que la moyenne c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
constaté le média les inrocks en 2015
l'écrasante majorité des tubes
américains s'étaient beaucoup de tubes
house dance floor clubbing etc et plus
récemment on a donc pu le constater avec
le succès de la chanson balla bèye 2 et
sheeran et son côté justement très
électro par
abc de fait est la preuve
alors bien sûr apprécié une tendance
mais ça ne veut pas dire que toutes les
chansons qui fonctionnent sont des
chansons joyeuses de clubs ou autres et
il ya plein de contre exemple on peut
citer et sheeran avec son titre et
estime qu' à première vue paraître assez
joyeux en réalité quand on regarde les
paroles et bien ils sont plus sombres
peut aussi parler d' adèle avec des
chansons comme sam en aurait q où l
homme qui sont assez triste ou encore
certain nombre de chansons plus
récemment billy ray fia donc la question
de l'ambiance la question des
thématiques ça à la limite on aurait pu
pas mal sans douté et poète iranien en
fait un autre élément important qui
pourrait expliquer le succès d'une
chanson c'est de trouver le meilleur
moment pour l'assortir
à l'origine c'était la chanson chez buzz
qui devait sortir en première mais
finalement il a choisi de sortir bas
nabitz avant donc pendant l'été car pour
lui et bien cette chanson avait plus de
chances de devenir un hit de l'été
le timing est donc très important et ça
beaucoup d'artistes l'ont bien compris
et généralement d'ailleurs eh bien ils
ont un calendrier de sorties de leur
musique qui est très précis vous l'avez
sûrement remarqué avant d'annoncer de
sortir et bien en projet long comme un
album la plupart des artistes ont
tendance à sortir d'abord des singles
donc des titres isolés seul qui n'y
faisait comme ça qu'ils vont venir en
quelque sorte faire la promotion de
l'album ensuite
c'est donc très important pour les
artistes de sortir des singles le départ
des singles qui peut devenir des succès
comme donc pas d'aa baisse des ide qui
peuvent donc permettre de faire
connaître l'album qui sort ensuite et
les différentes chansons qui la
composent et d'ailleurs là-dessus
certains en viennent même à se demander
si plutôt que de sortir des singles pour
ensuite annoncer un album eh bien les
artistes ne ferait pas mieux plutôt de
sortir que des singles en tout cas d'un
point de vue commercial ça pourrait
représenter un intérêt on a fait à
l'époque ça avait complètement du sens
de faire un album puisque on avait 15 20
chansons on les compiler sur cd on
vendait le cd et ont gagné de l'argent
en vendant ce cd et les gens peut
acheter ce cd pour écouter donc d'un
coup 15 à 20 chansons or aujourd'hui
logiquement c'est bien différent on peut
écouter n'importe quelle musique dans
n'importe quel sens de n'importe quel
artiste encore le truc et c'est là que
ça devient intéressant c'est que le
succès d'un sont sur une plateforme de
streaming de musique repose notamment
sur son intégration dans des playlists
public des playlists qui sont parfois
suivis par des millions de personnes et
qui combine des chansons de plein
d'artistes le résultat c'est quoi et
bien plutôt que de sortir un album avec
d'un coup 15 20 chansons en espérant que
certaines émergent et bien un artiste a
potentiellement plutôt intérêt à sortir
par ci par là régulièrement des singles
des singles qui de façon isolée on peut
être une force de frappe plus importante
et qui peuvent peut-être donc se
retrouver place et dans ses playlists
thématiques ou autre dp liste qui
permettent à chacun de ses singles
d'émerger et donc de devenir pays cette
stratégie s'est clairement ce qu'a
compris dany ocean qui est un chanteur
vénézuélien qui s'est clairement fait
connaître grâce aux playlists de spotify
en gros il s'est retrouvé dans deux
trois clés liste clés qui sont suivis
par des millions de personnes notamment
en amérique du sud en amérique latine ça
a commencé avec son sont mêlés au saut
puis après ça c'était le cas avec
d'autres chansons qu'il a publiés au fur
et à mesure il est attendu en réalité
plusieurs années avant d'enfin sortir un
album les plateformes peuvent donc avoir
un impact sur le rythme de sortie des
musiques mais aussi sur et bien la
manière ses chansons sont créés en tongs
telle est la manière aussi dont
certaines chansons vont devenir des hits
ou non en effet et bien les plateformes
de streaming de musique elle regarde
notamment si jamais une musique et
écouter en boucle ici une musique
écoutée en boucle par différentes
personnes elle va considérer que c'est
une musique du cou qui fonctionne et
elle va vouloir la poussée à plus de
personnes dans des playlists sur les
recommandations etc etc le truc c'est
que logiquement humainement on va
écouter plus facilement en boucle une
musique qui fait 2 minutes 30 que une
musique qui fait par exemple huit
minutes le résultat c'est quoi et bien
au fil des années les musiques qu'on
retrouve régulièrement tout en haut des
classements sur les plateformes de
streaming et qui peuvent donc
potentiellement à terme devenir des hits
musicaux sont des musiques qui sont de
plus en plus courte au fil des années
pour mais là aussi évidemment il ya
aussi des contre exemples comme par
exemple bande organisée en france il y a
quelques mois enfin dernière chose et
mais si on s'écarte un petit peu du
sujet des hits la dernière chose qu'on
peut noter sur les plateformes de
streaming c'est qu'elles peuvent
permettre de remplir plus facilement des
salles de concert c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'avait pas forcément en tête en
préparant cette vidéo et que les tirades
nous a tout simplement expliqué quand je
les rencontre et
green it now
des plateformes de streaming joue donc
un rôle important dans la façon de créer
un hit aujourd'hui mais faut aussi
mentionner au moins rapidement la
question des réseaux sociaux en effet
même si là dessus je pense que je vous
apprends rien ça est quand même
important et essentiel a mentionné
rapidement pour parler de leurs chansons
et en faire des hits et bien logiquement
les réseaux sociaux jouent un rôle
majeur un rôle qui est parfois même plus
important que le rôle des médias
traditionnels pour faire la promotion
d'une chanson et c'est notamment pour
cela qu'elle sheeran a dévoilé en
exclusivité son titre bad abaisse donc
la première chanson de son nouvel album
my worlds lors d'un concert en live sur
tik tok et plus largement que et bien et
sheeran devient lui même d'une certaine
façon un média avec une audience plutôt
importante avec simplement des dizaines
de millions personnes qui le suivent sur
chacun de ces réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
par ailleurs au-delà d'augmenter la
visibilité et la notoriété d'un artiste
jusqu'à donc faire des coups assez
incroyable comme li na 6 qui arrive à
faire parler très régulièrement de lui
et qui permet donc aussi de faire la
promotion de sa musique est bien les
réseaux sociaux peuvent aussi avoir un
impact sur la manière dont certains
chanteurs écrivent leurs textes en effet
l'une des façons pour un artiste d'être
visible aujourd'hui c'est de créer dans
leurs chansons ce qu'on appelle des
loopings snippet donc c'est des extraits
de leurs chansons de 15 à 20 secondes
des extraits qui peuvent être isolés et
devenir viraux sur tik tok notament ça a
été le cas par exemple avec d'aujac hat
qui a enchaîné les succès l'année
dernière et cette année et dont
plusieurs chansons ont véritablement
émergé sur tik tok à partir de ces
extraits isolé vous l'aurez compris il
ya pas mal de choses qui permettent
d'expliquer le fait que certaines
musiques fonctionne mieux que d'autre
n'a vu aussi que les plateformes de
streaming comme les réseaux sociaux
peuvent favoriser certaines approches
certains styles de musique et maintenant
évidemment la musique ça reste quelque
chose d'artistique c'est ce qu'en disait
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas de formule
magique loin de là parfois même
d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de surprises
on n'a pas de voir
ce
qui fait qu'il n'ya pas de recette
magique après tout c'est que la musique
elles évoluent à un art qui évolue dans
le temps les attentes du public aussi
peuvent changer au delà de ça d'ailleurs
sur parle d'ailleurs de réseaux sociaux
ou des plateformes elle aussi peut
évoluer dans le temps aujourd'hui ces
tic toc mais peut-être que demain ce
sera autre chose ce sera une autre
plateforme avec d'autres fonctionnement
et d'autres codes bref tout ça évolue
dans le temps il n'y a absolument rien
de grave et dans la roche quoi qu'il en
soit écouté j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura plus c'est le cas évidemment
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne pas
louper les vidéos suivantes on essaiera
faire d'autres vidéos comme ça sur
d'autres thématiques avec à chaque fois
à une personne très bien placé pour
essayer de répondre à de telles
questions j'en profite évidemment pour
remercier et sheeran qui a pris le temps
de répondre à toutes nos questions à
l'occasion donc de la sortie de son
nouvel album qui est désormais
disponible au passage on se disait dans
la vidéo c'est un album qui aborde plein
de thématiques et de sujets différents
donc je pense qu'il pourrait intéresser
pas mal d'entre vous et je me voulez
plus d'information sur ce nouvel album
rendez vous sur notre compte instagram
hugo décrypte point pop ou alors
directement en descriptions je vous mets
différents liens vols en tous cas je
crois que j'ai tout dis prenez soin de
vous et on se dit donc à très vite pour
d'autres vidéos dans ce style sur cette
chaîne youtube